whatever Monday you want is yours okay
so again good afternoon everyone please
bear with me there's been a lot of news
so I have a few things at the top so
with respect to the FAA system outage
that occurred early this morning the
safety of Americans is the top priority
of the president the Department of
Transportation and the FAA Dot and FAA
report that yesterday they were working
through issues in the no Tam system
which is used to communicate Key Safety
information about runways and flight
patterns with Pilots to be clear we're
not talking about Air Traffic Control
here but we still consider it this to be
a vital safety system as well
so FAA staff continued to work through
the night to resolve the outage and
issued a grand stop at 7 25 a.m this
morning which lasted for approximately
90 minutes
FAA lifted the ground stop once the no
Tam system was available again which
means that the critical safety
information required to resume travel
was indeed available the president was
brief this morning by secretary Buddha
judge before departing for Walter Reed
with the first lady as you heard
directly from the president on the south
lawn this morning for yourselves as we
shared this morning as well we do not
have evidence that this outage was
caused by a Cyber attack the FAA is
working aggressively to get to the
bottom of the root causes for the system
outage so that it does not happen again
bless you Emily
Okay so yesterday the Department of
Education proposed what would be the
most affordable student loan repayment
and plan in history the new plan if
implemented will cut monthly loan
payments in half for undergrad borrowers
it will mean borrowers making less than
about thirty thousand dollars per year
will not have to pay a dime on their
student loans each month and it will
reduce the time it takes for low balance
borrowers to get their student loan debt
forgiven The Proposal delivers on the
plan President Biden announced in August
to provide millions of borrowers with
more affordable monthly student loan
payments giving them additional
breathing room to start a family buy a
car and purchase a home today we have
further evidence of President Biden's
economic plan delivering for American
workers Q sells a major Korean solar
manufacturer announced it will invest
more than 2.5 billion dollars to expand
their plant in in Delton in Dalton
pardon me Georgia and to build a new
plant Northwest of Atlanta this
investment will create 2 500 jobs in
Georgia and represent the single largest
investment in solar Manufacturing in U.S
in the United States in its announcement
Q cells emphasize that inflation
reduction Act was critical to making
this investment possible this Builds on
on the more than 25 billion dollars in
major investments in Georgia in electric
vehicle and Battery manufacturing solo
manufacturing construction materials and
more since the president took office
when the president talks about building
our economy from the bottom up and
middle out this is exactly what he is
delivering more Investments more jobs
more Manufacturing in America in gun
safety news Illinois has now become the
ninth State Across America to pass an
assault Ban's weapon and take bold
action to keep weapons of war off
America's Street President Biden
commends the leadership of Illinois
noise Governor JP pritzer House speaker
Chris Welk Senate President Don Harmon
Representative Bob Morgan and the
numerous Advocates survivors and elected
officials whose tireless efforts turned
the pain of Highland Park and other
facts acts of violence into meaningful
action on behalf of all of the people
who live in Illinois as you've heard
from me before President
Biden has taken historic action to
reduce gun violence including signing
the bipartisan safety communities act
last summer and he has continued to
press for more action to keep our home
schools and communities safe including
federal laws requiring background checks
for all gun sales and a gun and a ban on
assault weapons and high capacity
magazines in the meantime the president
continues to urge other states to to
join California New Jersey Connecticut
Hawaii Maryland Massachusetts New York
Delaware Washington DC and now Illinois
to ban assault weapons at the state
level to save lives and finally
a quick note on yesterday's special
election in Virginia we congratulate
Aaron Roose arouse for his win in
Virginia's Seventh District a district
previously held by a Republican
he made his his campaign clear about the
choice Americans across the country have
between extreme Mega Republican policies
that would take away women's ability to
make their own health care decisions and
Democrats focused on expanding access to
reproductive care and lowering costs for
American families it's not just in
Virginia this was a of course a critical
issue in the midterms elections as many
of you reported
and in their first slate of bills House
Republicans are prioritizing legislation
that would amount to a national ban on
abortion it's not just tone deaf as a
republican Congresswoman Nancy May said
herself it's extreme out of touch with
the beliefs of the majority of Americans
around the country the president knows
that women's ability to make their own
health care decision is non-negotiable
and we will continue to fight to make
that cause that case at the state and
federal level and one final note on
Friday ahead of the president's trip to
Atlanta this weekend we will have a
special guest in the briefing room we'll
have a senior advisor for public
engagement Keisha Lance bottoms will be
joining us will be joining me to talk
about some of her work as well as
preview the significance of the
president's remarks at Ebenezer Church
on what would have been Martin Luther
King Jr's 94th birthday with all of that
said
you guys can start waking up now
um Zeke won't you take us away
the president
you saw the first lady don't want to put
out a brief statement a couple minutes
ago but what has the president been
doing he's supposed to get the pdb at
one o'clock did that happen while he was
up there so I'll I'll say this and be
very simple simple today is about his
wife that is the focus for the president
right now as many of you know the
president accompanied the first lady to
Walter Reed National Medical Center for
her schedule outpatient procedure
commonly known as Mao's surgery the
first lady's procedure is proceeding
well and as expected Dr O'Connell will
provide an update about her uh her today
but again this is about the Pres this is
about the president supporting his wife
of 45 years and so again when it comes
to her conditions specifically Dr
O'Connor will have more to share but
again I'm not going to go beyond how
important it is for the president to be
there with his wife today thanks for
that a couple specific questions
regarding the discovery of apparently uh
documents classified president's former
office the president acknowledged
yesterday that he had been briefed that
those doctors when was he briefed by
those documents have examined so let me
just lay this down a little bit because
there's some just for folks who happen
to not be following this look the
president addressed this issue uh
yesterday he interested on uh um
in Mexico City on a world stage in front
of many of you at a press conference
with two of our closest neighbors as you
all know and he said he takes classified
documents and information seriously he
was surprised to learn any records had
been found found there he doesn't know
what was in them he said this just
repeating what the president has said as
soon as his lawyers realized these
documents were there they did the right
thing and immediately turned them over
to the archives as he said his team is
cooperating fully with the review and we
also released a statement from the White
House council's office as you know on
Monday which had which had which had
information detailed information about
the particular situation as my call
colleagues in the council have stated
and said to all of you yesterday this is
an ongoing process under the review of
the Department of Justice so we are
going to be limited on what we can say
here but but as as as the president told
you as my colleagues have said to many
of you we are committed to doing the
right thing uh doing the doing this in
the right way and we will provide
further uh further details uh when it's
appropriate you want to do this the
right way presumably that I mean it's
the transparent way so my question was
when was the president brief he said he
was freaked when did that briefing
happen again I'm not going to get into
the details I'm not going to get beyond
what the president shared yesterday
he laid out what he knew when he knew it
he laid out how important it is he sees
it seriously very seriously when it
comes to taking classified documents and
information I'm just not going to I know
you all are going to have a lot of
questions on this but at this time I'm
not going to go beyond what the
president said yesterday I'm not going
to go beyond what my colleagues from the
White House Council shared with many of
you as well on Monday and so I'm just
going to leave it there want to be
prudent here and and make sure that it
is that my colleagues really truly
handle this issue one more step at this
because again this is a lot of
importance to people president mentioned
that handling classified information is
important these documents were
discovered in November 2nd this wasn't
this didn't come public until my college
at CBS News uh reported this on Monday
that's more than two months later why
was the public not informed while the
White House prepared a PR response for
two months again this was under review
this is under review by the Department
of Justice I'm not going to go beyond
what the president shared yesterday I'm
not going to go beyond uh what the my
colleagues at the White House Council
shared with all of you as well uh look
what you received from the White House
Council on Monday was uh had uh complete
details a lot of details to all of you
on what occurred and just not going to
get beyond that it is again an ongoing
process we're going to respect the
process as the process as the president
said his team handled it the right way
and we're just not going to get ahead of
the process from here thanks great have
you spoken to the president about these
documents and their Discovery I have not
I have not spoken for well first of all
I have not spoken to the president about
any of this specifically because he's
laid out what he knows uh he has said he
he doesn't know what is in them so
there's no way for me to talk about the
documents if he has said he doesn't know
what's in them and we're just going to
to allow the process to continue so for
the sake of the American public who want
these questions asked and answered would
the president characterize what happened
here as a mistake would this White House
characterize this as a mistake what I'll
say is this is an ongoing process you
heard from the president he spoke about
this in detail yesterday in front of uh
on a world stage in front of uh in front
of many of you who were there in front
of many of your colleagues he laid out
what uh what he knew he said that he
seriously he takes this seriously when
it comes to classified documents when it
comes to information that is classified
he was surprised to learn about the
records had had been there and again he
believes that that the um that the
lawyers did the right thing and they
immediately turned them over to the
archives saying that he was surprised to
learn about these documents is he saying
that he did not bring those documents to
that office I'm just not going to go
beyond what the president said do we
know who did bring those dogs I'm not
going to go beyond what the president
but you're saying you want to be
transparent
way or yes and and his team of lawyers
did do that they did the right thing by
turning over the uh by Antonio River
documents to the archives that's what
they did once they realized that they
had them and uh that they were there
well it's not clear how the documents
got from the White House
Steve I appreciate the question it's
under review I'm gonna let the doj do
that do their process I'm just not going
to get ahead of it on the FAA outage has
cyber totally been ruled out
right now that is what I said we do not
uh this has not been viewed as a uh
there's no evidence of a Cyber attack at
this point uh the president has directed
Department of Transportation to conduct
a full investigation into the causes and
provide regular updates again this is
incredibly important a top priority the
safety of Americans who are flying uh
every day we want to make sure that
they're safe this is a top priority for
the president top priority for the
Department of Transportation and
certainly FAA and so we want to make
sure that we get to the root causes so
this does not happen again lastly on the
first lady when was this lesion
discovered I'm not going to I'm not
going to get ahead of what Dr O'Connor
is going to share later today uh I I
stated that the procedure is going well
I'm just going to leave it there and let
and let her doctors speak to speak to
on the documents case again you've laid
out that the president's lawyers the
special counselor dealing with the legal
side of this you've now laid out that
you have not had a conversation with the
president about this
but this was reported Monday it happened
in November are you aware of any
conversation in the West Wing among
others
people other than the president about
disclosing this once it was discovered
what I can say is somebody I was asked
uh by your colleague If he if we we
talked about the documents themselves
the president said he does not know what
was in them right but I but I but also
just wanted to clear that up I look I
understand you guys are going to have a
lot of questions on this I get that I
know you guys are going to have a lot of
questions on process and specifics and
what I can tell you is that I'm not
going to go beyond what the president
laid out I'm not going to go beyond what
my White House counsel colleagues have
stated I would refer you to them for any
other specifics or additional
information I want to be prudent here I
want to make sure that we do this in
appropriate the appropriate way
that's our job I understand and my job
is to answer your questions so here we
go let's go
speak on like day two of this
Administration when he saw all of you
with the president said quote I'm going
to make mistakes when I make them I'll
acknowledge them and I'll tell you and
I'll need your help to help me correct
them so you're the one here
yeah among us about this that's why
we're asking you so let's just remember
that all right Ed I'm we don't need we
don't need to have this we work very
well together I don't we don't need to
have this kind of Confrontation ask your
question and I will answer them the best
that I can part of the reason laying
that out is because you're laying out
you're part of the job
I know but I'm just saying that we don't
need to have contention you don't need
to be contentious with me here and the
president was asked yesterday but did
not answer this part of the question why
didn't he or someone in the White House
and form the American people when these
documents were discovered on November
2nd they didn't have anything to do
because people are asking this part of
it did it have anything to do with the
fact that the election was just a few
days away again Ed this is under review
by the Department of Justice it is
literally under review right now as we
are as as I as I am talking to you it is
under review so I'm not going to get
beyond the process I'm not going to get
beyond what the president said look the
White House Council my colleagues in the
White House Council laid out a very
detailed uh information about uh what
this particular issue on Monday you all
have that I'm just not going to get
beyond that the Department of Justice is
independent as you know they're they're
doing a review and I want to be prudent
here and it would be more appropriate it
would be more appropriate for my
colleagues in the White House councils
to office to address this that we walk
into the briefing room we hope they can
come soon to discuss this but there's
another thing there was nothing stopping
the president United States
from disclosing the discovery of these
classified documents in his former
office
before it was under justice department
review
what I can tell you what I can tell you
right now is what the president is is
share with you what the president said
to all of you right which is he was
surprised by this he definitely truly
respects the process here and also when
it comes to classified he takes
classified documents very seriously and
again I'm going to leave you to the
information that the president provided
to all of you and also just yesterday in
front in front of many of you or your
colleagues and also what my White House
counsel uh colleague shared on Monday
the leaders of the Senate intelligence
committee today like they did after the
raid of Mar-A-Lago have asked that the
Director of National Intelligence
conduct a national security assessment
of this
apparent discovery of classified
information
has the president asked for one or are
you I would refer you to Department of
Justice here if this is again this is
I would refer you to Department of
Justice on this particular issue that's
being reviewed currently on whether the
office of Director of National
Intelligence when it comes to the review
that we are currently speaking of right
now of these classified documents I
would refer to Department of Justice
okay apart from those classified
documents the president did say that he
was unaware of of Records being brought
to that specific office so aside from
those
has he asked his lawyer has he uh looked
into whether any other documents have
been taken to any other uh any other
office that he has whether in Wilmington
or Rehoboth has there been any kind of
like audit that's been done of uh where
where he may where there may be others
that he doesn't know about
just not going to speak to this I'm
going to uh let the process continue
it's an ongoing process and so I'm just
not going to uh to speak to this from
here it is more prudent and more
appropriate for my colleagues at the
White House Council on another note you
were you were touting the Q cells
announcement uh and the inflection
reduction act
um I just want to ask though you know
Governor Kemp and Georgia that is also
you know touting the deal and taking
credit for it did the administration
work with the Republican Governor to get
this project off the ground how much
help was he in this in this process I
don't have any specifics to share on uh
on our conversations with the governor
of Georgia but what I can share with you
is what we have said many times is how
important the inflation reduction Act is
here and we see this we see this uh in
in many of the announcements that we've
seen across the clearly across the
country when it comes to making sure
that um making sure that we're lowering
costs for Americans making sure that
we're bringing manufacturing
manufacturing jobs back home and this is
part of more broadly the president's
economic policy and so we see this a lot
we see where Republicans do not support
some of the major critical policies like
the inflation reduction act but then
take credit for it like the American
Rescue plan but then take credit for it
but that also shows you how effective
the president's economic policy has been
and how it does indeed work and deliver
for the American people and so I'll just
leave it there does talk about
bipartisanship I mean did did Governor
Kemp help it does I just said I don't
have anything to lay out for you but
what I'm sharing with you is what we
have seen over and over again when it
comes to Republicans who do not support
what we're trying to do on behalf of the
American people again the inflation
reduction act again the American Rescue
plan right which is all part of the
president's Economic Policy which has
shown to have worked which has shown to
actually create 10 10 million more than
10 million jobs which have actually
helped to lower help lower in cost when
you think about the inflation reduction
act as we're going to move forward in
implementing that so all of these things
are incredibly important I'm just laying
out to you that the president's economic
policy is working go ahead
um when you're talking about the FAA you
said that the issue uh arose as they
were working through some uh issues and
so I was wondering if you could explain
a little more if basically the FAA was
trying to update the system or or was
there a server issue a database issue if
you have any more detail on how exactly
you know prior to the full investigation
this seems to have happened so I I would
refer you to the Department of
Transportation secretary Moody judge has
been on many of the of your colleagues
Airwaves speaking about this and what
occurred he has directed uh an after
action process to determine exactly the
root causes and recommend the next steps
FAA and D.O.T will continue to be
transparent here about the causes of the
issue and and how we will ensure a
system outage of this magnitude does not
happen again so number what I said
earlier which is very true our number
one focus is to make sure that the
safety of Americans who are flying right
we want to make sure that they're safe
and the second part of this is to make
sure that this does not happen again and
so again there's going to be an after
action process and we'll move from there
I asked about this gas stove thing that
kind of bubbled up yesterday
um does the White House think gastroes
are safe and I know that the consumer
product safety commission said today
that they're not looking to ban gas
stoves but I'm wondering was there
communication between the White House so
as far as the safety piece of it it's
not something for us to answer from here
I would refer you to the consumer
productive product safety commission as
the chair said today and I quote
Research indicates that emissions from
gas stoves can be hazardous and the cpsc
is looking for ways to reduce related
indoor air quality hazards but to be
clear I am not looking to ban gas stoves
and the cpsc has no proceed and has no
proceedings to do so look as far as our
conversation with to your question we
are in regular touch with them but of
course they are an independent they are
independently they were independently
correcting the record on this for
several days now and so as far as I'm
aware we're not in touch with them on
this particular issue again I would uh I
would refer you to their to their
comment quick one um Russia announced
today that they're replacing their
military Chief in Ukraine they've
installed
Kremlin loyalist there I'm wondering if
you have a reaction to this and what you
think it says about sort of the state of
data so look I'm going to let the
Kremlin speak to their leadership
decision uh but as an outside Observer
as we all are here they are they sure
have a lot of changes
um you know they made a lot of changes
as they uh continue to try to overcome
their own difficulties uh in a war that
they shouldn't happen in the first place
so again I'm not going to comment for
them I'll I'll certainly let the Kremlin
speak for themselves but again this is a
war that they started this is a war that
they created a brutal war and they can
end it today if they choose to do so
thank you Kareem I have two questions
for you last week President Biden said
that the war in Ukraine is at a critical
point and then you repeated the
statement from this Podium
so I'm wondering where does this
assessment come from uh and why the
White House thinks that the war in
Ukraine
is the critical point right now and
secondly Poland announced today plaster
sent a company of leopard tanks to
Ukraine as a part of International
Coalition does the U.S support uh
such a coalition and is President Biden
considering sending American appearance
thanks to Ukraine to help especially if
he thinks that the war is at critical
point so I'll say this look Russia has
uh has been attacking Ukraine for 10
months now 10 months and this winter
we're seeing a new approach by Putin
targeting civilians you've heard the
president talk about that specifically
it is unspeakable what the Ukrainian
people are enduring and and they are
bravely fighting back I'll say this to
your to your second question the
president has made clear to uh to
president zielinski as you know he was
here very recently you saw them stand
side by side and you heard the president
talk about the commitment that he has
for the Ukrainian people and that the
U.S will continue to have their back
stand with Ukraine as long as it takes
and we've been very clear and consistent
on that we are moving fast and deliver
delivering to support Ukraine with the
tools it needs to win this war we just
announced a PDA of three billion dollars
the largest one just last week and so
that is going to continue again we will
be with them uh as as long as they need
us I'm going to move on I'm going to
move on
um
do you have a reactions
increase the price of its covet vaccine
by 400 so I I don't have it I don't have
a response to that I would have to check
in with the team this is the first I'm
hearing about this
separately uh due to a reaction to
Governor cassandis a couple days ago
about going to activate the National
Guard in the spread of Florida National
Guard in response to the Cuba migration
surge so we have known uh for some time
now right we've seen Governor DeSantis
do political stunts that is how he how
he perceives to fix uh the uh this issue
from Florida right and uh and he takes
uh you know he we're talking about
people who are coming from from
countries who are dealing with um
political Strife who are dealing with
issues uh where they're they're trying
to find Asylum and he treats them like
pawns and so we have called that out
over and over again and we will continue
to do that and he is not dealing with
the problem he's actually creating a
problem and uh and so that's what I have
to say to that we've talked about
Governor DeSantis and the uh again what
the mockery that he's making of the
process that the president is trying to
fix uh he's trying to deal with this
issue he has made when you think about
immigration reform a priority by putting
putting forward a piece of legislation
on the first day of his administration
and what he's going to continue to call
on is for congress Republicans uh to uh
to actually take action and really deal
with this crisis this issue okay Uncle
Ray and a couple of questions one
um is there a law
showing how many times the president has
been to that office uh
during you know his vice president when
he was vice president Etc is there a law
showing the times that he traveled there
travel to where the office to that
office
yes you mean since he's been vice
president oh since he left as vice
president yes I I do not know of such of
such a log
nothing look I I I'm not sure you're
just trying to see how many times he's
gone to pen the pen Biden Senator office
I don't I don't have anything to share
about how how he's I mean at least for
the last two years right you guys have
been very aware of where he goes right
because he has a a protective pool that
travels with him at all times so I can
only speak to the last two years when he
was a a citizen right after becoming
vice president I cannot speak to speak
to uh his movements there where he's
been or how many times he uh was there
as you know he worked at University of
Pennsylvania so clearly he was there
often but as president you guys are very
much aware of his uh movements and where
he goes uh and the trips that he takes
because he is indeed president of the
United States so I can't speak to speak
to after that oh before that you spoke
with the legal aspect of it there is
also a political aspect to this as well
um there are some Republicans who are
grabbing onto this cloud of documents
that have been reported
what do you believe will happen how will
the work for the American public go
forth with Republicans already talking
about investigations already Margie
Taylor has been screaming impeachment
for the longest and now with this she's
saying impeachment how does the work of
the American public move forward as now
documents are reported that were in an
office connected to Joe Biden again I'm
I'm going to sound like a broken record
but the more prudent thing to do is to
make sure that my colleagues are dealing
with this my colleagues in the in the
White House
Council Office and I want to respect the
process this is an ongoing process as
you all know that is being reviewed by
the Department of Justice and I'm just
not going to speak beyond that
I know you're talking about the police
I understand I'm just not going it there
is an ongoing process that is being
reviewed by the Department of Justice
I'm just not going to speak beyond that
lastly the Atlanta trip can you talk
about what this moment uh with this year
being the 60th anniversary of the March
on Washington what does this thing
holiday mean to this president
this holiday as every holiday when we
talk about the legacy of Dr Martin
Luther King when we remember him on his
birthday has always a been a critical
moment for this President you heard him
talk about the reasons why he decided to
run a lot of it had to do with civil
rights and um and he has an
Administration that makes sure that no
one is forgotten that there is a that he
has an Administration that represents
the country one of the most the most
diverse Administration in modern history
and that also shows a commitment to how
he he believes to to uh Dr Martin Luther
King Jr's Legacy as well and making sure
that we walk in that Legacy every day I
don't want to get ahead he's going to be
speaking as you know at Ebenezer Church
in a couple of days and he wanted to
make sure that he recognized that day by
going there and and talking about the
legacy of Dr Martin Luther King what he
meant not just to the black community
but to every Community just across the
country to Americans
great thank you so much President Biden
campaigned on a promise to stay true to
the spirit of transparency
why then how is it possible that the
White House did not reveal the presence
of these documents prior to the election
when they were found again the president
spoke to this personally yesterday you
heard him at the press conference he
laid out he laid out what he knew and he
talked about how important and how he
sees this as a serious matter when it
comes to classified documents and
information he talked about when about
how he was surprised to learn about the
records that were that had been found
there and he laid out his process and
his thoughts I'm just not going to go
beyond that again we released
information that was very transparent
meaning the information that you all
that received from the White House
council's office and I'm just I I know I
I just I know you all are going to have
a lot of questions I get that and I
understand that but I'm not going to go
beyond the process that's currently
happening at the doj does it undercut
the president's promise of transparency
that the documents were not revealed
revealed several months after the White
House discovered
you know
so when his lawyers realized that these
documents were there they turned them
over to the archives they did the right
thing they turned them
all I can say is what the president said
yesterday I would refer to his comments
but they did the right thing by once
they learned of them they turned it over
they turned it over to the icon archives
because this is the question I
understand the question but there is an
ongoing process it's being reviewed by
the Department of Justice Just when it
is appropriate for us to say more we
will otherwise I would refer you to the
White House counsel's office I do want
to be very clear about something you
said make sure I understand you
following up on one of my colleagues who
asked you you have not spoken to the
president about this you were you
traveling with him no the way I heard
the question is have you talked to the
president about the documents and I'm he
doesn't know what's in the documents
that's the way I heard the question so
that's the way I was answering the
question talk to him about the
revelation of these documents yes we've
talked about the CBs story we talked
about the revelation of the documents
obviously but about the documents itself
what's in them that is something that
the president doesn't even know and I'm
just going to leave it there okay has he
conveyed to you when he was briefed and
if not can you go back and get that
answer I've I've not talked to the
president about that what I can tell you
is I know you all have a lot of
questions there is an ongoing process
here and so I'm just going to let the
process finish before we follow I want
to let you respond to former vice
president Mike Pence who talked about
what he and his mother Republicans are
calling a double standard with the
Department of Justice Mr Penn said the
kind of double standards that we see
being practiced by the Biden
Administration in the wake of this
incident in the Justice Department I
think is exactly what undermines public
confidence in our justices
again as soon as his lawyers
realize these documents were there
they did the right thing and they turned
over the documents to their archivist
that's what they did as soon as they
realized uh what was the documents were
there and his team is cooperating
fully with the review again there's a
review Happening by the doj
and we're just going to let the process
move forward
[Music]
hey screen um just to follow up on
Franco's question given the physician
you're holding right now
there are no assurances you can provide
at this point that there are no other
classified documents out there any other
office in our home again this is an
ongoing process so I'm going to let the
process continue it is being reviewed by
the Department of Justice and I'm just
going to leave it there
and you reference to the council's
statement that there are limitations to
what you all can say at this point in
time do those limitations just for
clarity's sake extend to literally
everything beyond what the special
counsel said on Monday night and what
the president said last night
there's the White House Council my
colleagues are here to answer questions
on this particular issue and I am just
going to let them speak to this they put
out on Monday a very uh a very um uh you
know informative transparent statement
about this particular issue so I'm going
to let them speak to the to this any
further but as for as for me as for here
I'm just not going to go beyond what's
happening currently
this one the president over two last
night you kind of as well the idea of
once this is kind of all over or wrapped
up there will be more information there
will be more details if you have a plan
for that is there how should we expect
that additional information to come in
terms of complete detail everything you
know once this is done how does that all
work so has the president told all of
you uh yesterday we are committed to
doing the right thing here and we'll
provide further details in a at
appropriate time and that's all I can
share at this time
the U.S travel Association says today's
FAA catastrophic system failure is a
clear sign that America's Transportation
Network desperately needs significant
upgrades so what specific steps are
underway to ensure that outages like
this won't happen again so the notam the
no Tam system is continuously being
updated that is something that is
happening on a regular basis as
secretary budijat said today dot is
asking the FAA how we improve the system
to ensure it is a state of the art every
five every five years there is a review
of the FAA authorization and that is
coming up this year so we welcome the
attention from Congress to ensure the
FAA has what it needs to address these
issues the FAA is working aggressively
to get to the bottom of the root causes
of what happened with the system outage
today and making sure again making sure
that it doesn't happen again clearly the
safety of Americans who are flying every
day is a number one priority and what
they're going to do was to make sure
that this doesn't happen again how
concerning is it for the White House
that there's no backup no contingency to
this system when it when it does fail
well
um what you saw happen today was out of
abundance of caution uh the action that
was taken because again the the safety
of Americans is a priority they're going
to get to the bottom of this there's
going to be an after action
document that's going to be put together
and so we will make sure that the what
the president wants to see is to make
sure that this doesn't have occur again
could you tap into funds from the
bipartisan infrastructure law for
example to try to make some of those
upgrades that you're talking about well
we'll see uh we'll see what the after
action report shows I don't want to get
ahead of that as far as any funding and
what needs to happen next
thank you Kareem first does President
Biden have confidence in transportation
secretary Buddha judge yes why
as secretary Buda judge is a uh is he
respects uh the secretary and the work
that he has been doing uh you have seen
the secretary on TV you've heard you
have spoke probably spoken to him
yourself and they are doing everything
that they can to make sure that the
experience that Americans have uh is a
good one that's why they've held the
airlines accountable you've seen the the
secretary do that over and over again
and we understand we understand what uh
what Americans have been going through
these past couple of months that's why
the secretary has been very clear on
making sure that they are held
accountable has put in processes in
place to make sure that that occurs and
yes the president has confidence in
Secretary judge and then on these
documents how could anyone be that
irresponsible
isn't that what this President says
about mishandling classified documents
the president spoke to this personally
he spoke to this personally he again he
he classified documents and information
should be taken seriously he takes them
seriously and he was surprised to learn
by any any records I disagree I disagree
here's what happened here's what
happened once
well let me let me explain to you the
process here's what happened when his
lawyers found out that the documents
were there they immediately turned them
over to their archives but they
immediately turned them over to the iPad
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna go into
specifics but I'm going I what I am
reiterating to you is what you heard
from the president yourself Peter which
is how he saw the process and how he
respects and truly uh uh respects and
takes this very seriously and when he
knew and how surprised he was by it and
the actions that uh the the right
actions that the lawyers took again this
is under this is under investigation is
under review by the Department of
Justice and we're going to let that
process continue how can President Biden
be trusted moving forward with American
Secrets because his lawyers his team did
the right thing but he had a closet with
he classified employers did the right
again again again
he was surprised that the records were
there he spoke to this personally he was
surprised that the that the records were
there and when his lawyers found out and
his team found out that they were there
uh they turned it over to their archives
and now it's being reviewed by the
Department of Justice and just one more
why didn't President Biden want to see
what's really going on at the border he
did see exactly what's going on at the
border you didn't talk to any migrants
and he didn't go anywhere that people
actually cross illegally why not but he
also but he met uh he went to the my the
Migrant Center which was a critical
critical place to be when you think
about the partners uh who who are our
partners who are helping uh support uh
the migrants on the ground there uh
there happened to be no migrants at the
facility at the time that he visited but
let's but let's say
Rush the shelters are full there are
overflow migrants sleeping in the
streets and then it's just a coincidence
that suddenly the president shows up and
what if we talk about what's going on in
Paso uh
daily prior to the president's visit by
about 70 percent
and that's a good thing Peter that's a
good thing that we we've seen the
numbers go down and that is something
that we should be saying okay that's a
good job there it has helped ease
pressure all across the community but
the president visit
had nothing to do with it and so look
again uh we went he went to a Migrant
Center he went to one of the busiest
port of entry which is in El Paso uh and
uh and so the president got to see he
went to the Border he got to see for
himself talking to we've always been
very clear that we were going to he was
going to talk to the people on the
ground who was who who's working on the
border and that's what you saw you saw
him meet with the CBP you saw him meet
with Partners on the ground as I just
stated who deal with migrants and their
families and the President also is going
to continue to call on Congress to take
action look the president has been doing
the work and if you think about the
record funding he has done he has done
more than any prior prior president to
secure the border and build a saved
orderly and Humane immigration system
and that's what the president has been
able to do we've got 23 000 agents
working to secure the border and will
soon be hiring 300 more that's what the
president has uh done here and so again
he went down there he saw for himself
and uh and I'll just leave it there
um thank you okay
um was there any discussion of President
Biden getting a physical while he was at
Walter Reed this morning or could you
provide any update on when that might
happen next again this is about his wife
today uh he wanted to uh he wanted to be
there uh to support her I don't have
anything else to share besides the fact
that uh you know this they've been
married for 45 years and he wanted to be
there with uh Dr Biden during this time
and then I just have one quick question
on Brazil has there been any discussion
in the administration about if there
were to be an extradition request from
Brazil for bolsonaro uh for the event
that happened this week so I don't have
an update uh for you on this I'm not
aware of an official request for
information for extradition from the
Brazilian government the though of
course if we were to receive one we
treat it seriously and examine it
carefully as we generally do for for
such requests just not aware of one at
this time
good morning thank you um a follow-up on
the gas stoves and just a quick one on
the president's op-ed today on social
media on the gas stoves question Senate
Democrats are calling for more
regulations on gas stoves because they
contribute to indoor air pollution is
the president worried about the climate
impact of a gas stove
so look again I that when it comes to
the question about safety or um uh or
the effect of gas stove that is not
something that that we can speak to here
at the White House so I would refer you
to the consumer product safety
commission uh and you know the president
does not support Banning gas stoves and
the consumer product safety commission
which is independent is not Banning gas
stove so just want to be very clear on
that on that and so again that's not
that's not something that we can make
from here about the safety of a gas
stove uh that's not something that the
White House can can provide on the
president's op-ed in the Wall Street
Journal about social media he talked
about reforming section 230 but the
bottom line just the Press did think
that social media companies should be
legally responsible for what goes on on
their platforms so look holding big big
technology big Tech accountable has been
a priority for this President since the
most of the day he took office in July
of 2021 his competition executive order
explicitly called for enforcing anti us
laws to meet the challenges posed by new
Industries and Technologies including
the rise of the dominant internet
platforms and addressing the
surveillance of users it is also part of
his Unity agenda had you heard him say
last year talk about his Unity agenda
and you may recall in that Unity agenda
he he talked about the four areas that
have traditionally been bipartisan and
where the president believes we can make
bipartisan progress and in his op-ed he
urges Democrats and con and republicans
in Congress to pass a bipartisan
legislation look the president uh again
outlined the same policy positions in
this op-ed today that you saw that you
heard from him in the State of the Union
last year he said it's time to
strengthen privacy protections ban
targeted advertising to children demand
tech companies stop collecting personal
data on our on our children and also you
may remember that the one of the
president's guests the first lady's
guest at the State of the Union was was
Francis Haugen the Facebook Facebook
whistleblower so this is an issue that
the president's going to continue to
focus on and at this and is incredibly
important to him and so as the new
Congress starts he's going to continue
to reiterate a bipartisanship there
does he think that social media
companies need to have some skin in the
game where they could be sued over what
happens on their plan when it comes to
sectional reforming of section 230 he
calls for he continues to call for that
increasing competition reducing the
impact of tech companies uh have our on
our over our lives extends back to the
campaign and he has reiterated that them
as as president so he's going to
continue to do that he's going to
continue to call for a bipartisan
legislation as we're seeing the new
Congress and that's what you're going to
hear from the president and also that's
why he wanted to lay out uh this uh His
Thoughts with the new Congress and the
op-ed thank you Corinne uh can I get
your reaction on the new house like
committee on China does the
administration plan to work with them do
you believe they will be helpful in
achieving your goals in strategic
competition with Beijing and are you
concerned about the potential for
anti-asian hate so look uh under
President Biden we are more prepared to
out-compete uh China protect our
national security and Advance a free and
open indo-pacific than ever before many
of our efforts we have been pursuing are
bipartisan underscoring the alignment at
home on the key issue we look forward to
the committee getting stood up and will
continue to work with Democrats and
Republicans in Congress on this on this
on this issue it is a top priority as we
talk about uh out competing China just
on the last part do you do are you
concerned about the potential of the
committee perpetuating any kind of
anti-asian hate look that is something
that we're gonna We will always call out
against uh that's something that you've
heard from the president and you've
heard from this Administration calling
out any anti-asian hate that is not who
we should be or who we are and so uh
again that is a commitment that he has
to the Asian Community
ahead of the prime minister's visit can
you share the goals of this this visit
particularly in terms of you know in the
context of countering China and holding
Russia accountable on its invasion of
Ukraine if you can be specific about
what this visit particularly means in
the U.S Japan strategic relations so let
me just more broadly the two leaders are
going to have extensive and in-depth
conversation over the last year at the
East uh over the last year at the East
Asia Summit in Cambodia so they're going
to continue that conversation continue
that relationship and the bilateral
visit and quad Summit in Tokyo as well
so they have had many extensive
conversation the Prime Minister will
arrive at the White House after
Consulting closely with us and Regional
Partners on the release of Japan's New
National Security strategy and
commitment to boosting its defense
depend on to two percent of GDP
including to invest in new defense
capabilities these unpresented
unprecedented moves will strengthen
deterrence in the region in order to
advance peace and stability in the
indo-pacific and globally as you as we
as you asked me about China this meeting
also comes as Japan continues to be
critical partner for the United States
and Europe and holding Russia
accountable for its brutal war against
Ukraine the meeting between the
president and the Prime Minister will
highlight the pivotal movement moment we
are in for the U.S Japan Alliance and
underscore how President Biden's focus
on investing alliances and partnership
including Japan is bearing fruit and you
will hear from more on about this
meeting and we'll get a readout on
Friday
yes going back to Transportation TSA
plans to roll out facial recognition
technology at its airports Nationwide
but critics have raised concerns about
the racial inaccuracies especially for
Asians and African-Americans when it
comes in this technology what is the
White House's response to this racial
disparities and what kind of oversight
can be provided to ensure that there
isn't this inherent bias in this
technology so the tstsa continuously
evaluates and improves upon technology
and process to better protect the
traveling public and ensure that
screening is conducted in a manner that
respects the Dignity of each individual
that is clearly a priority DHS is
working with an nist to assess the
performance of face recognition
technology and reduce demographic
differentials particularly as it relates
to race and gender and so that's what
they're going to continue to do is
evaluate evaluate and improve can I have
a question
can I just ask if you have any
information about why the president's
personal attorneys were at the Penn
bides that are in the first place were
they looking for something specific was
there something specific they were doing
going through these documents it just
seems like to send if it was just
routine moving stuff to send a personal
maternity I would refer you to the white
house council's uh very extensive
kind of information on on Monday that
they provided so I refer you to that
green cream thanks so much
um
only
um a grand shop this morning it's just
such an unusual procedure I'm wondering
if you can go through in any more detail
when the president was told that this
might happen and
um you know was he involved in the com
in that decision or that conversation
before it was issued or did he learn
afterwards if you just could provide a
little more detail about how that
process so when it comes to the ground
stop that's something that the FAA a
decision that that they made in order
that they uh made so I I'll send you to
them as far as the president FAA worked
on this issue as I mentioned as you've
heard from secretary Pete throughout the
night and brief secretary Buddha judge
and brief secretary budget early this
morning and then in turn the secretary
then briefed the president and he spoke
to to you all directly shortly after and
so that has been the process on how the
has the president was was briefed
president knew before this ground stop
or if he was told immediately afterward
uh he was told before
and then I am sort of looking back to
the summit um that that were not major
announcements On the Border or fentanyl
and I'm wondering you know what that
what we should take that to mean in
terms of the the success of the summit
so as it relates to uh migration
irregular uh migration obviously that
was a key topic of discussion as all of
you know uh president bind discussed
ways our countries can continue to work
uh work together and to address
irregular migration so that conversation
certainly happened extensively he
discussed the recent announcement of
additional enforcement actions coupled
with expanded Pathways for Cubans
Haitians nicaraguans and Venezuelans and
the leaders were able to agree on a
number of initiatives including a
virtual platform through the Los Angeles
declaration website which will provide
migrants when one unified location in
which to access legal Pathways they may
be eligible for as well as establishing
physical centers where migrants can come
in in person access those legal Pathways
as well and so that again it was an
extensive conference station on
irregular migration when it comes to
fentanyl we've been focused on taking
big actions to fight drug traffickers
and go after financiers of cartels
attempting to bring fentanyl into our
country and so during his meeting with
uh president obador the president
discussed increased cooperation to
prosecute drug traffickers and dismantle
criminal networks disrupt the supply of
illicit precursors chemicals used to
make fentanyl as well shut down drug
Laboratories and prevent trafficking of
drug arms and people across our shared
border so there was there was a
commitment in coordination and on Law
Enforcement Training the best practices
so we can better go after criminal
networks in the fentanyl trade again
this was uh this was a a meeting a
summit that happened to our closest
Neighbors on how we can move forward in
dealing with some of the issues that are
really important to uh to the three to
the three leaders
as ambitious as you had hoped I mean it
was the way it has a little you know let
down by the scope of the agreements and
can you get sort of characterized you
know how you're feeling at this moment
about
you know the outcome so we believe we
announced a robust uh uh set of
initiatives on issues that are critical
to North America that's what you saw
from the three leaders you saw them
yesterday in Mexico City answer
questions speak to uh the different uh
kind of the different issues that matter
to their uh to their country and look
just a couple of things that includes
expanding and deepening our security
cooperation to combat drug trafficking
as I just laid out redoubling efforts to
address climate change by taking efforts
to reduce methane emissions and
decarbonize public transportation
strengthening and expanding North
American Supply chains for
semiconductors and critical minerals and
providing alternatives to irregular
Migration by increasing ways migrants
can access legal Pathways to North
America again we believe those were
robust set of initiatives uh continuing
their close friendships as we move
forward to uh to what's important and
critical to North America
order we were wondering that we're not
Republican members of congress with the
president were they invited to come with
him was
can you sort of talk through that yeah
so um I I was asked about this a couple
of days ago look we go through the
normal process uh as we go into a state
uh with whether it's Republican Or
democrats uh in that state
um and just don't have anything further
our office of legislative ledge Affairs
certainly reach out to Congressional
members are intergovernmental Affairs
certainly reach out to State and local
official as you saw the governor
governor Abbott met with met the
president at the uh when he arrived at
the airport and so again this is a
regular we have a regular process that
we we uh we uh we go forth with every
trip and there was nothing different
here
did reach out to Republican members and
the way that we reach out to their
federal Offices like we always do with
that with every trip and then one quick
question just following up on April's
really a good point she in her question
brought up the the notion that
um you know President Biden was really
former Vice President Joe Biden During
the period in which these documents were
found and can you tell us how many other
offices there may have been I realize
that you can't say whether they're being
researched or whether there is any sort
of look for documents but how big is the
scope of additional offices where the
that at that point former vice president
was you know doing work look this is an
ongoing process and I'm just going to be
Putin here and it would be more
appropriate for my colleagues to answer
my colleagues at the white house uh
council's office to address to to
address this again I want to respect the
process and so again I would refer you
to them
I was gonna say one quick follow on that
um obviously he said he was surprised
about
documents being found has he expressed
like any other emotion in response to
these you heard directly from the
president uh yesterday about this
particular issue he answered it in a
personal way uh again I would refer you
to his response and how he saw the issue
I just don't have anything else to share
beyond what the president shared with
you and the American people yesterday
we'll see you tomorrow thank you thank
you
human